hello everybody my name is prestige or
the prestige plans you might see in my
youtube name and this is something
different for me I have not really done
any call of duty except for my first
gameplay and yeah so hello my channel is
mostly minecraft but if you see her for
the call of duty then don't get at ER by
that since I got a few announcements so
I was planning on doing this channel
update wait until I get to 500 but I
already had some gameplay and I kind of
just want to do it now and I kinda
wanted to make with the subscriber thank
you so boo to the 500 subscriber thank
you right now I'm at around four hundred
subscribers so on thank you guys is my
first thank you it really means a lot
that 400 people have subscribed to watch
daily what I put up I don't really
understand that but you guys seem to be
all gung-ho about it so thank you for
that and I said there's gonna be a
channel update so did Joe actually ones
like the gameplay it's not like some
crazy Katie or anything I play hard
objective end up going having like a to
Katie going like 72 in like 34 or
something like that but I just I just
gameplay cuz it's so objective and like
so close that it just what everything
works amazingly miss like they both the
teams are is a great matchup and it was
just a really fun game to play so i
thought i would show you guys it now
back to the channel tape so my channel
update is kind of taking the channel in
some different directions now for all
the people that are subscribed to me yet
so far don't worry i will post minecraft
videos till the day of this channel dies
this that this channel is minecraft will
always be a part of this channel don't
worry so i will always put my graph cube
world we'll see where that goes I'm not
not feeling too confident about it but
if you guys seem to go more Hank or on
it and likes and views
than sure i'll watch it I mean sure i'll
post more of it sorry and yeah then up
to what we're seeing now call of duty
now you know the new call of duty ghosts
is coming up now I originally started
YouTube doing kind of minecraft with my
aunt sorry sorry apologies apologies
mainly mainly doing call of duty now my
old channel in about two months more
than what it took I've been on this
channel I've got I got 300 subscribers
lesson about tomb in about like six
months I got around about about a
hundred subscribers it was great and all
but this this channel doing a lot better
now something like so that kind of
deterred me away from doing the call of
duty because I can also when black ops 2
came out I wasn't bad I was a bad
commentator I was bad youtube I really
didn't have my bearings so I wasn't
destined for success so I thought why
not give it another shot with c.o.d
ghosts coming out this fall and that's
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna be posting
CB ghosts gameplay I'm gonna try getting
out there daily content i'm gonna try
doing more daily minecraft because i
haven't been doing devi and it's summer
I'm gonna start school soon and I really
haven't been doing as much as I should
so I'm sorry but i'll try and change
that that that's definitely something
that I want to change I want to start
posting more so expect more harappan
experience expect more any random stuff
that I do in Minecraft and yeah and now
back to this so she'll be ghosts I'm
gonna be doing to be ghosts like
multiplayer probably no campaign if they
have anything like spec ops I might do a
few videos about it but don't expect
anything basically multiplayer kind of
gun guides other tips and tricks a fun
gameplay if I happen to do well and get
top kill streaks which I've been
terrible in colder to getting I've been
like
three nukes in modern warfare two black
ops had nothing of that um mom or 43 had
the Moab I I got like one of those and
I've gotten like five or six swarms and
this call of duty so I'm I can do great
in community I'm like I'm a good call
duty player I'm not like amazing but I'm
pretty good but I just can't get a
little I didn't stay alive for a long
time I don't know maybe there's
something in my style playing maybe I
rush too much I'm too hasty but yeah so
I'll be doing more i'll be doing some
tacos so people who subscribe to me for
Minecraft don't don't be running out the
door don't be being like oh we call
Jimmy get out of here since this is my
this is what it kind of what I've been
thinking about if you said if you like
my minecraft videos then subscribe to me
from a Minecraft videos and say I start
doing fall duty videos if you don't like
call of duty and just don't watch those
or if you are found call duty and you
really like my commentating then watch
it from my voice since it won't always
I'll do a lot of commentators I'm
actually I'm hoping to you a lot of
commentaries that kind of like this
we're just here some gameplay it's above
average good or it could be great I
don't know and just talking about other
stuff I got a lot of requests do that
even doing minecraft which that kind of
Bob the bottles my mind like just a
minecraft gameplay I don't know but if
you guys wanna oh I will totally supply
video I'll totally do it for you guys
whatever you guys basically whatever you
guys want I mean posting unless in some
weird game never heard of and I play it
and it's terrible so yeah oh you in see
if he goes also um I told you guys want
to do the Q word if any of you watch the
cube world video my first one then you
know that I said I was getting a new
computer which i hope i'm getting a new
computer later this year and that also
needs if i do that i'm going to be
getting battlefield 4 which looks
awesome and if i get that game then also
be in battlefield 4
so this is this a big update yeah
continue monograph we have call of duty
which I've never done and we have
battlefield which I've never touched on
like I do I've is my second video call
duty I've never touched on battlefield
up all on youtube so hopefully that go
that well and probably something similar
what I'm doing called duty except
battlefield help on that for gun guides
class guides and maybe ryan a comic
covers about fun stuff cuz that's always
fun to do now quick quick note on the
gameplay here I'm just me rushing and
dying a lot I'm just doing my best like
see I got killed right there but I got
the guy was gonna play at the bomb I I'm
just going hardcore for the objective I
guess all i care about i don't care
about hi Katie you know Katie's badness
to two kitties nothing to be ashamed of
I don't even have to dating I'll do that
like a one point for now thank you
however huh huh what I whatever tangent
apologies so yeah I'm gonna try my best
I doing all that plus all my school work
and stuff and yet so it's gonna be a
definitely a really crazy ride so this
year and next to you because I'm gonna
be a junior in high school which is like
you're crazy a year everyone's like
stressing out like Oh SATs get into
college yeah yeah yeah and I'm gonna be
sitting here playing video games so
that's kind of funny but um yeah so I
hope you guys are excited and I know
basic basically anybody that's watching
this video is a Minecraft thing because
only a Minecraft subscribers at the
moment I'm assuming some of you like
call of duty since just by statistics
since a lot of people play call of duty
and if you don't even really if you
really really hate call of duty then
don't watch it and if you can't imagine
being subscribe to somebody who does
call duty then I'm sorry the door is
always open
it was fun have you I hope I wish you
the best in your YouTube subscribing for
a year and yeah don't don't stick around
if your hater like it on call getting
sup cuz that's no fun and that's yeah
the videos Oh got a little more time sir
I'm not reckoning but I'd say watch the
videos that you like and don't watch the
videos you don't like or if you really
don't care but what the videos aren't
you like my voice then hello there and
those are the creepy apology but some
people some people will just close out
gain will close out the video just
listen to me talk and play the games
which I've done that before I've done
that with a much you to resign oh so
it's not that weird it's cool it's jill
and yeah so hopefully everything will
work out well i'll have a good good
success with call of duty and yet and
anybody that aging call these hoes
anything i know it's the same thing but
i like playing it like guys and i used
to play soccer so i play soccer every
year is the same thing but i still
enjoyed it same thing with call of duty
or manga you just play it again getting
it call duty however you can buy it
again and getting the end lanka don't so
plus for the Minecraft but yeah just
it's an enjoyable FPS kind of want to
start it on so that's that's why I
really like it and also it's really good
get a start on youtube if you know what
you're doing and last last time I didn't
know what I'm doing hopefully this is
gonna be a little redemption for me
personally I don't most of you guys like
I had like 10 subscribers come over from
a previous channel so most you guys
don't know so yeah that's basically it
it's very gonna wrap up last kill
awesome hope you guys enjoy this you did
leave a like rate comment subscribe and
cheers to a new future
you